[Music]
in exactly one hour from now
a series of blasts will bring this place
to the ground
if anyone tries to enter or negotiate
with me
i will kill everyone
grandpa where's your dad
kyle i know your wife left you but i
think you need to find your
purpose doing the best
getting kind of dangerous out here these
days it's an election year and my
customers are my voters and not the
president
yeah but you're on your way everyone
this is the one and only sam nelson
let's do this
[Applause]
attention shoppers i am wearing a
suicide vest
you hear me sam nelson you belong to me
i'm going to destroy everything you love
sam
uncle luther rotted away in prison and
somebody's got to pay
everything's going to be all right jesus
kyle
what's marine always a marine
what is this it's hot find him
how are you doing i'm a product of chaos
looking for you
all we know is to kill you we will find
you
i know you were here
let's go soldier
you admit to what you did all these
people died
[Music]
foreign